check this out food and wine reports
that you can now order frank's hot sauce
by the slice that's right they're a
company called slice of sauce which just
got a 200 000
investment from a-rod on shark tank and
they already offer ketchup by the slice
and now they're adding frank's hot sauce
and sriracha and a pack of eight slices
goes for 5.99 which i feel is a very
good bargain well you know i love sauces
so much they should call me sauce
matthews
and this is some this is some jetson
stuff right they've taken the sauce that
you should pour on and made it a slice
and can we try it yeah let's try it
oh my god
oh it's wonderful
i
love it okay here's the deal it's like
if you put sauce on it but there's a
texture to it can i just eat it yeah why
not oh wait drew just try it as a slice
oh my gosh i know you're very welcome
it's like a fruit roll-up
but spicy that is so good
it is like a fruit leather uh-huh um
our next guest is someone who is one of
the world's authority on hot sauces he
is also one of my favorite journalists
interviewers and some of the most famous
people in the world sign up to get in
his hot seat for a multitude of reasons
one because he's so intelligent and
researched and he has an amazing
mechanism for the show and he just
kicked off his 14th season
hot ones and i actually had the honor of
sitting in the hot seat you did it yeah
take a
look hot sauce has a way of humbling you
especially this one
you know my daughter actually olive
[Music]
gave me some tips actually
what are some of the tips
she said
never stop chewing
and fast be fast
smart girl
um i also noticed
that it seems like people make a mistake
by licking their lips so i'm trying not
to do that
shawn are you there
hi
we're up here thank you so much for
having me oh
it's quite the opposite shawn how are
you
i'm doing good feeling good
um what ross and i are loving this slice
of hot sauce what are your thoughts on
it besides that tabasco thing where it
delivers one drop at a time i don't
think that there's been anything in the
way of innovation with hot sauce so i'm
actually on board with this slice
because also too with hot ones one of
the problems we were having with these
remote episodes drew you know all too
well is guess over dumping the sauce so
i guess if there's a way to quality
control this all with a slice i'm
curious and i'm cheering it on from the
sidelines hot ones is it everybody wants
to be on the show
was there
early on
the light bulb of like this is why this
will work you know it wasn't that
popular at first you know now the
youtube
view numbers are big but at first we
used to joke internally i'm like i'm
eating a lot of scorching hot chicken
wings and no one seems to care like at
all i'm not sure this is worth it uh but
one of the tentpole episodes that we
always talk about was the key and peel
episode which was like while it was
happening it was there's so much
excitement in the room and i could feel
good internet happening while it was
going on and then that was the first
episode that was the big millions and
millions of views trending on reddit
number one on youtube situation and then
it's kind of been a runaway train ever
since
sean will you do some news with ross and
i
i'm excited that's what i'm here for
that's what i'm waiting for
okay well we're going to start with some
business news famous shark and
billionaire mark cuban is launching a
brand new venture complex reports that
the mark cuban cost plus drug company it
will do something amazing bring low-cost
prescription drugs to the market and
they're launching a hundred different
drugs this year starting with a pill
that treats a stomach parasite usually
costs 225 but they're bringing that
tablet cost down to 20
so he what he's doing is he stays like
really putting his money where his mouth
is it's what billionaires should be
doing right using
what they have to make life a little bit
better for everybody you know i had to
go out and get health insurance for the
first time on my own a few years ago and
that's when i realized how impossible it
is how difficult it is and i think that
you know maybe that's the next
disruptive opportunity for these tech
companies is is to not only make that
process easier but also protect from the
price gouging that you see in
prescription drugs all the time i love
mark cuban for this and thank you for
doing that all right super bowl is
coming up and everyone should buckle up
for an epic halftime show by the weekend
people magazine reports that he wants it
to be so perfect he spent seven million
dollars of his own
money on it because he and his team have
spent six months working on the
performance to make everything possible
that he envisions sean thoughts the
weekend in addition to being just one of
my favorite artists he's so
cinematic in his music videos so i'm
really excited to see what he does if he
has a blank check from the nfl i'm sure
it's going to be amazing when i see on
instagram like everyone else that he's
going to kendall jenner's halloween
party and he dressed up as the nutty
professor that makeup is like academy
award level makeup when he dresses up to
go pick up an award with his
headdressing like making some weird
plastic surgery statement this guy comes
to play and he does not phone it in so
i am just very excited to see what he'll
bring he's such an artist yeah he's
going to be exhausted he's going to need
a weekend
well in honor of your 14th season sean
um ross and i have a little something
here and we would love
oh god
get our hot sauce on with you i am so
ready for this so we have uh quite the
spectrum here that first sauce the
classic it's a louisiana style table
sauce probably not all that different
from the frank slice that you guys were
just snacking on that middle one the los
calientes rojo kind of a turning point
sauce a mid-level sauce but then that
last one eye of the scorpion is
basically just pure scorpion pepper and
it is outrageously hot i am scared for
you guys okay i'm trying the first one
and it's a nice heat that's good i can
do that
child's play okay okay we're gonna move
on to the medium one
bring it on
sean that middle one's like um that
one's hot for for rossi okay
we hit a peak child's place
this last one is is outrageous it can
almost be illegal it's just basically
pure scorpion pepper you're doing it
oh
okay here i go you guys
lost
loss okay
drew is a star dome is it starting to
hurt
uh
it is growing
it pillows
three do it rozzy do it do it do it do
it do it do it do it do it do it do it
nope
oh oh it's okay
this one's good sean when do i start
panicking
i'm wishing both you and ross a speedy
recovery because i know that that last
sauce and pillows and and one last thing
drew just careful around the eyes right
yeah i know i know you told me that last
time and look i so quickly we forget
sean
thank you
[Music]